what's up you guys this is this past
weekend this is this past weekend too
many this is already here we go use
Google Maps and my mom is somewhere else
but when I found it our pet shop where
it's been is too quiet for me dude these
guys look like they're all the same guy
by the way they're versions of the same
guy this is Spy vs spy if they were a
bath without that
it's funky though huh
and then what just fade it out funky
though it's very funky it's very real
people ish this is this past weekend in
case you [ __ ] don't know an
April Fool's [ __ ] April Fool's
collective [ __ ] you understand this is
this past weekend and that's Bishop gun
shine and they kill it huh they kill it
they look like the same dude three times
in one band like some guy made a band
like like Jesus Christ was like we got
to make a band but I but I'm but it's
late it's late in the day and I'm tired
as [ __ ] so just use that three guy just
use that one guy three times and that
and what we gonna call them Bishop gun
that's what we're gonna call them that's
a real working man song working man's
song there here we are at [ __ ] this
past weekend and it's Chris D'Elia here
and April Fool's on you [ __ ] so
this is what's up man this is the
episode of this past weekend here you
got your guest host Chris D'Elia and I
came here and let me tell you first of
all my first impressions now I've done
this podcast before with you as a guest
but I don't think he's ever had a guest
host right no this is me this is me and
I'm here and first of all they got way
too many computers on this [ __ ]
right here there's two desks two
computers and and I walk in it's always
a hard to get into this place because
they shoot the fighter in the kid here
too and all I think they do the any time
they try and capture somebody on To
Catch a Predator they do it here in one
of the rooms but I I get here and you
know I I sit down and you know what this
[ __ ] you know you know when you you know
when you go to your friend's house like
you hang out your fridge you hang out
with your friend a lot you
in uh in in in in class but then you go
over his house and like you meet his
family and [ __ ]
and like you're like oh then it's
there's a gonna overwhelming sense of
smell and you're like that's what my
[ __ ] friend really smells like that's
what I feel right now in this podcast
this [ __ ] is house Theo smells and it
smells and I'm gonna tell you right now
you know how we roast each other we'll
roast each other all day long you know
but this [ __ ] smells good dude
Theo smells good as [ __ ] and I want you
to know that no ro I don't give a [ __ ]
dude this is how confident I am I'll
come in here as a guest host
I won't roast a dude I'll come in and
tell you if you smell good you smell
good this dude smells bonkers I'm being
serious
and the thing about Theo is maybe if you
look at him like in passing you'd be
like that guy smells probably janky as
[ __ ] but he doesn't dude he doesn't
smell janky as [ __ ] he's got a high ass
like a black guy but he doesn't smell
janky as [ __ ]
Theo's ass is in his shoulders and
that's a problem but he smells good as
[ __ ] though this is how Theo wipes his
ass like that
hahaha and that's gangster but uh Theo
looks like he would be in Bishop gun he
looks like he's probably the DP of
Bishop gon be like we gotta get another
guy that looks like you but I think
they're friends so shout-out to Bishop
Gunn that's all kind of rocks that song
pretty much rocks and I don't listen
that kind of music but that that's like
some pickup truck type kind of just
cruising down the whatever freeway 942
freeway or whatever the [ __ ] some
interstate that I've never heard of that
goes on for way too long that they built
in 1901 and you're just cruising along
listen to some Bishop gun with your lady
that's like a little too chubby but you
love this [ __ ] out of her and the chubs
are in the right areas too like she's a
little bit pear-shaped but also on a
good day when she boost those right
areas up it feel it Lily you're like all
right and the sun's coming down on the
942 freeway and you're just [ __ ]
right there you're right there with them
you're like sweetie let's get in the
back of the
can thing or whatever let's get in the
back and just kill it there's too many
belts in this room there's too many
belts in this room and I'll tell you
that much - there's the [ __ ] fighter
in the kid belt which Theo won twice and
then there's the fans like give them
belts dude give them belts to take home
from the road imagine like you got to
take all this [ __ ] did I get art working
all that and sometimes I get like cuff
links I'm like things from my dogs and
[ __ ] but he's got belts to it people
just give him belts and he's got like
chunky belts people who don't know who
Theo is they give him [ __ ] chunky
belts and he's just walking down walking
through the airport with chunky belts
haha dude he's like wearing a chunky
belt with another chunky belt over his
shoulder oh my god this past weekend man
we're trying to get the code we see this
is what this is this April Fool's
cross-promotion type [ __ ] man we trying
to bring the cults together I don't know
if he'll calls you should have called my
shits a legit cult dude and people think
that our beef is real people just want
be beef to be real all wrestlers beefs
are real we're wrestlers I'm not saying
it's not real or not but um yeah do it I
drove here it's way too far by the way
it's in like another it's in basically
Sacramento this studio but this [ __ ] is
uh you know this [ __ ] is good I'm on the
road a lot and you know you pass
comedians at the airport saw a comedian
a little while ago on at the airport saw
Alonzo Bodden saw Steve another comedian
named Steve something can't remember his
name
and I definitely should remember his
name but I can't remember his name but
it's okay because you don't know who I
was named I don't remember but never in
it - never in it - Theo let me uh
oh by the way when I got here I came
with sushi and I was gonna eat it during
the podcast to be super respectful being
respectful being disrespectful is
respectful like if I come to Theo's lair
right
and and we're just and I'm like okay I
want to I'm a guest of the podcast but
it's my podcast now this episode is my
podcast but I'm a guest and I bring and
I bring sushi and I eat it during the
podcast people be like well that's
really disrespectful why didn't he eat
the sushi beforehand or after I did he
did I did end up eating it beforehand
but I wanted to eat it during him
because that's the most respectful you
could be me being comfortable in Theo's
area is like accepting it's like in like
Saudi Arabia when when when they're like
oh when you mention you like something
to a family and they have to give it to
you you know we're like oh that's a nice
pony and they're like it's yours and
you're like no I know how am I gonna get
it back to [ __ ] in Nebraska and they
were like you have to take it otherwise
we cut your hands off you know that's a
real thing
that they do you'd be like nice lamp and
they say it's yours like not I want the
lamp they say you take it order you die
that's what they do in Saudi Arabia um
and so you see so you can't say you're
like stuff in Saudi Arabia otherwise you
got to bring a lot of [ __ ] bags
because they'll put the stuff in they
see you say wow that's a beautiful
painting they say open your arms and you
say why and they say do it or to lose
your hands and you say okay you open
your arms they take the painting off of
the wall and they put it in your arms
and they say close your arms and they
say bye and they say that the painting
is thirty five thousand dollars you're
welcome and say I don't want this is it
get on the pony get the [ __ ] out of here
and then you got a gallop with a [ __ ]
painting off to the Saudi Arabia
International Airport on a pony with a
painting of like probably a pony you're
on a pony with a painting of a pony
that's like the most Saudi Arabian [ __ ]
that's the most American American in
Saudi Arabia [ __ ] you could do hey why
do you listen to either of these
podcasts by the way all we do is
[ __ ] but we thank you for it we
really do I love the fact that these
comedians can come on these podcasts
start a podcast by the way cheater
Santino I have no idea what his real
name is but he started a podcast a week
ago and the guys are already charting
that's great it proves that can meet
have personality I don't know you know
half the [ __ ] I say is is just you know
[ __ ] and I know Theo too and chido
Santino and whatever his real name is
and byron Kallen and you know that big
beefy boy over there but you know is
what it is right you guys keep it mad
cold in here too but you know I got my
North Face jacket on because they sent
it to me and that's very nice so shout
out to North Face and yeah but you keep
it cold and it's like ice hell in here
but it's okay I wouldn't want it's
probably a regular regulated thing I bet
Theo feels like he has a real job to
come in here you know like I do that
[ __ ] in my house [ __ ] that dude if I
could have a Comedy Store in my house
and somehow not have it be creepy and
have it be like where people would show
up to my you know if people who like
would want to come see my show wouldn't
be creepy but they would show up to my
house and I wouldn't have to worry about
them like stabbing me or like taking
pictures and [ __ ] I would do that I
would keep I want to keep by the time
I'm 65 if I I'm gonna have a Starbucks
in my house
I [ __ ] them I have a coffee bean in my
house cuz Starbucks oh is it just
straight-up awful and you know it
but yeah so how about the people that
are like majorly pissed off too about me
doing one episode of this that I was
just like you know I'm [ __ ] Thiele fan
and not a Chris fan we can just go over
to [ __ ] congratulations and you
listen to Theo April [ __ ] fools
that's some gangster [ __ ] Oh guess what
dude exposing Theo
guess what he uses a [ __ ] HP computer
Oh Nick he's trying to take Nick's
trying to take the rap it's mine it's
mine shoutout okay shine dude you didn't
shoot ok shine that was Diddy in the
club do you know I'm talking about
what's that [ __ ] I don't mean shine
the song by Bishop gamma I got I mean
shine the [ __ ] in the rap remember that
rapper remember that rapper know you
what are you [ __ ] you're like
31 all right so maybe not shine rapper
you do write rapper he took the rap for
P Diddy even though P Diddy shot the
[ __ ] remember this [ __ ]
this song is this that song that they do
he uses an HP it straight up is the last
one that's the last HP that ever came
out and see I was like I'll take it and
then he said to [ __ ] Nick Nick right
he said hey if anybody ever asked just
we police say that that shows you this
one house this guy not biggie is what I
want to know dude the best is the guy in
the back that's just silly Radley Billy
diddly diddly well the guy didn't know
didn't know she they're like we want you
on the what you want a truck he was like
what you want me to do is like just [ __ ]
around guys like alright so
disrespectful [ __ ] literally diddly
diddly well oh that's so gangster to be
able to sing like that dude if I could
sing like that
do you understand if I could sing like
that I wouldn't do anything but sing
like that
you know musicals how people just break
out in songs and you just buy it and
[ __ ] that's what I would do in real life
and I would expect people to come back
and do the [ __ ] other parts and
they'd be like what are you doing
[ __ ] and I would be like dude this is
a musical shitty badly be literally
literally with Little Italy oh say words
I guess not though dude if you could
sing that well why say words that's
actually some genius [ __ ] shine went to
jail because he [ __ ] took the rap
when did he popped off the Glock when
did he when diddily diddily diddily
billy diddily diddily diddily popped off
the Glock and shine said and i heard
that did did he did it no I don't know
no I don't know because when that
happened I was 17 and I just there was
barely the Internet because I'm 38
so but you know what was I even saying
by the way before I got to the shine
part I have no idea I have no [ __ ]
idea what was I even saying see this is
why by the way also feel I found out
another expense so here's an HP and he
does the podcast alone in his room do
you know what that means
he's crazy that's what that means you
can't if you're in a room alone by the
way it's what eight feet by four feet
it's a cell it's a cell with artwork in
it it's a cell with [ __ ] with boots
and too many belts in it and a painting
of Chris Farley it's a cell and he talks
for an hour and 10 minutes in his cell
and [ __ ] by himself nobody's in the
room dude he did like four episodes with
Nick and that's it all the other
episodes that don't have guests in it
gone gone it's just him gone is him out
to lunch in his cell talking and just
because he put cameras up he's not crazy
bro I have people in my room you know
how many people are in the room when I'm
doing congratulations 45 to 60 people in
the room are in the room and it's small
as [ __ ] and we're all talked away like
sardines but it doesn't matter dude
because I'm not crazy one time I asked
my dad when I was a kid you know when
you're a kid and you like don't know
really what words mean and you're just
like and you're just like so curious
about the world
I had a park like that I would walk to
and just walk into that park Janna
called Brook Park I would just walk
around in that Park
and I would just kind of think about
life you know at one time I tried to
light a tree on fire and a cop came by
and he was like hey this is kind of kind
of kid I was dude I start I still I
tried to light a tree on fire I wasn't
trying to light the tree on actual fire
okay but I I would I was with my buddy
Matt ravenna and I put the [ __ ]
lighter to the branch and I wanted to
see if it would light
and the cot there was a cop car in the
park you know how a cop car the cops
will just like do the [ __ ] what and
that's it
just to like you and you'll be oh god
and always [ __ ] comes out a little bit
of [ __ ] comes out always like if you're
near if you're anywhere - if you're two
blocks within [ __ ] this [ __ ] and you
don't [ __ ] you're a [ __ ] robot
congratulations you have circuits
because that is the scarier there's
nothing scary there there's nothing
scarier than that dude there's nothing
scarier than a cop car within two blocks
going well and then you [ __ ] a little
bit comes out and you go well that's
just natural right unless you're a robot
and then they're like did you [ __ ]
yourself you know what yes but not me I
am a robot so I tried to light this
branch on fire and the cop pulled the
[ __ ] Boop and I even know I was like
[ __ ] eight and cops I didn't even
know cops could drive on parks you know
like I had no idea that a cop car could
just drive up in a [ __ ] park next to
a lake but of course okay they're cops
right so my buddy made my preventing my
buddy much of it I was like oh let's go
face the music and he starts walking
towards the cops and I walked the other
way because always get away from cops do
you know what I mean that's me so match
Venom's like let's face the music and I
was like uh deliberately deliberately
DeLeo
I'm gone dude I'm gone and then Matt
goes like this hey Chris at the cop car
and I was like yeah the cops are just
watching me and he said you need to come
here I was like what okay
and I walked over and I was like hey and
the cops were like hey what are you
doing I was like oh well I just wanted
to see if the branch would catch on fire
but I realize that's a stupid idea now
and he was like he can't be doing that I
was like yeah I know actually
and then you drove away out of the
[ __ ] park
it's funny how cops probably think
they're super badass driving in a park
like by the way I've been approached a
few times in a in a park by a cop on a
[ __ ] cop car they probably feel real
gangster when they're rolling up cuz
they're like we do [ __ ]
we're outlaw [ __ ] right but
then because they could do whatever they
want but then they always look real die
lows real dumb when a cars on grass I
don't care who how cool you think you
are that shit's bumpy as [ __ ]
that's bumpiest [ __ ] you know the
[ __ ] you're like knockin around and she
and your fat cuz you're a cop cops are
so fat always do it in LA the cops are
jacked but in New York and New Jersey
hey cop dude I mean eat a [ __ ] leaf
for Christ's sake
eat some grains dude these cops cops eat
me dude you know I'm talking about like
people will be like all cops eat
doughnuts [ __ ] that they eat meat man I
my cousin was a cop my my cousin my
cousins dad was a cop was I made him a
cop I think basically that's it but uh
my cousin oh by the way dude if you
don't listen to my podcast this is what
it is dude I just [ __ ] never stuff I
don't even know I was gonna make a point
and then I started talking about shine
then I started talking more cops in a
park and then I started talking about
this but my cousin was a yeah it never
really comes back around it's like a
[ __ ] it's like a movie you'd watch
that at the end you'd be like what
happened to the [ __ ] one guy that's
like my podcast so anyway I get to the
so I had I had a cousin named Jimmy and
then I his his dad was a cop and his dad
loved my grandma Carmela
Italian I have a grandma Carm Z hahahaha
so Italian she would make meatballs and
they were [ __ ] so good but uh yeah
she
[Music]
whatever she she she had a friend was a
cop that was a there were cousins I
guess while my cousin Jimmy he actually
died he's dead now but not to bring a
[ __ ] damper on the whole podcast but
he um what do you call it
oh god that guy wanted to be a
bodybuilder so bad we went to Vegas once
but it was really big and one time he
was like hey you he was like did you do
it death you ever do a death pool I was
like huh and he was like yeah me and my
brother we got a death pool I was like
what is that and he was like [ __ ] it's
actually [ __ ] cuz he is dead now so but
he was like it was like me and my
brother we we got a death pool going we
add money every year and then whoever
dies first the other person gets all the
money
I was like really that's morbid as [ __ ]
and he was like yeah and I was like
Jesus Christ I was like well how much do
you put in every year and he said at $20
and I was like okay so alright so and he
was like 27 at this time I was like when
did you guys start it he was like two
years ago said oh so you got and I'll
never forget this I said oh so you got
and he said it with me he said yeah
forty dollars in there right now bro
I'll never forget it - he was wearing a
tank top that said Venice lifeguard ah
nothing's more New Jersey then we're in
a Venice lifeguard tank top that was
like too low so it showed his [ __ ]
titties you know and he was just like
you ever do a death pool and I was like
no cuz person and he was like yeah and I
said oh well that's [ __ ] crazy man I
was like well well where do you [ __ ] you
not this is my family I said well where
do you put the [ __ ] where do you uh
where do you guys keep the money you
know and he said ah he's got it
[Music]
we got he said we got in a safe place is
that his house and I said yeah whoa uh
do you know where it is and he said nah
and I said whoa uh what if what if he
dies first he's and he goes like this oh
yeah I guess I shouldn't know where it
is
and I said yeah otherwise you won't ever
get the money he said yeah he said I
said well and they said I guess we
should probably give it to my mom or
something and I was like you're gonna
give your mom that death pull money for
her sons and he was I guess I said by
the way you just started this you put
like 20 bucks in a year when you die or
if he dies he's in a yeah yeah I said
how much gonna get he said I don't know
a few thousand dollars
Mike bro by the way he died when he was
like 32 so his brother one [ __ ] a
hundred and forty bucks
not a good consolation imagine being
like [ __ ] what's that what's that [ __ ]
imagine a man I met just imagine the
scene this [ __ ]
imagine this [ __ ] are come on see this
is why I need [ __ ] this is why you
need another guy bro but this is imagine
this [ __ ] just like this and you're like
damn I can't believe I can't believe my
brother died like yeah he was a good one
huh yeah it was just like yeah that's
[ __ ] horrible huh yeah ah damn just
in his [ __ ] Venice tank top in his
Venice lifeguard tank top just taking up
one of the [ __ ] shoulder straps and
just wiping his Italian eyeballs just
all beefy so said him sorry ma and she
goes and she says yeah we sure loved him
didn't we by the way
[Music]
is that $140 oh [ __ ] oh yeah from the
death pool right yeah Wow you know I
tweeted the other day about how [ __ ]
ridiculous bagpipes are like hey dude
first of all bad pipes are ridiculous
because you should definitely figure out
a different way Scottish people to make
it look every time a guy does bagpipes
look at an octopus is attacking him okay
this changes the look now bagpipes in
any other instance but a funeral funeral
funeral
is a [ __ ] straight-up travesty
bagpipes are hey hey Scots you doing
with bagpipes but if someone dies that
[ __ ] kicks ass and you know it
you have so much respect if you [ __ ]
play bagpipes the guy could literally
they could literally Bill Cosby could
die
Harvey Weinstein could die they could
[ __ ] kill any bad person or just die
of old age and then all of a sudden
during the funeral you'd be like okay
well you know what honestly he wasn't so
bad
Wow um uh yeah do it
Wow rest in peace Jimmy acres man I
loved hanging out with that [ __ ]
dude loved it I went to Vegas with him
once and we came back and when we came
back so I had what I used to do jujitsu
for like years and I haven't done
anymore you could kick my ass but um and
I had this I had ringworm because you
always got ringworm doing jujitsu and
there was a gonna outbreak in the
[ __ ] place and then we all got it
anyway it was on my wrist and I had this
[ __ ] yellow tape that I would put
around my wrist so I wouldn't give it to
other people when I shook their hands or
you know their whoever the [ __ ] I don't
want to give it to Jimmy so I wrapped it
around but anyway so he was driving back
from Las Vegas in my car [ __ ] I missed
this guy man and and he came and and he
was driving back from Vegas and I had
that yellow gauze I looked at my cuz I
never you know you ever go on your
drivers on the passenger side of your
car that shit's weird right that's like
seeing your schoolteacher out somewhere
besides school you're just like oh man
this is the thing this is where people
usually see my car oh you know and you
think it's interesting even though
you're a [ __ ] brain-dead idiot
because that's not interesting it's just
your [ __ ] three feet over so I was
there and I was like it's kind of cool
cool and we were on the 15 freeway or
whatever the [ __ ] came back to Los
Angeles and we got we were and I opened
the drawer the driver's license license
driver what do you call it the [ __ ]
what'd he call that [ __ ] glove
compartment so I opened it up and
there's that yellow gauze that I had and
I was like ah yeah [ __ ] I remember this
it's like I wonder if I could I was like
I bet Jimmy won't realize if I [ __ ]
wrap that gauze all around my face I was
like if I wrapped that girl was all
around my face I wonder how long it'll
take for him to notice that all that
yellow gauze is wrapped around my face
so I leaned my chair back a little bit
took the gauze and I wrapped it all
around my face I mean I look like a
mummy dude
and the only thing that was open were
the eyes and I was chillin there bro I
was chillin there for about about
honestly 25 minutes and we were just
listing the music he was changing
stations and he was telling me stories
dude about New Jersey and he had a tank
top on for sure dude and and I was just
yeah we were talking yeah I was like
yeah that's true and he looked over me
and he goes and he says oh damn you got
will you got on your face and I was like
Isaac I just wanna see how long it take
you to notice and he was like oh no way
how long has that been there and I was
like I don't know like 25 minutes he's
like really and I was like yep haha dude
if you don't have friends you could do
dumb boring [ __ ] like that with you
ain't [ __ ] dude get yourself a Jimmy
Akers man get yourself a friend with a
death pool honestly dude get your friend
get your do a death pool bro give you
from hook your friends up with $140 when
you die when you die hook your friends
up with $140 that's that's that's so
dope you know why because then they
could go out to a nice dinner
[ __ ] leaving people millions [ __ ]
leaving people a hundred thousand 50k
give them a nice dinner bro and I die
all my friends are getting 140 bucks I
got to put that in my will I gotta make
a will I gotta make it will I'm gonna
make a will but I think I might have one
I'm not sure dude you know my mommy
called me dude
so yeah so we go so we got [ __ ] one
fire dude I brought my crew with me I
got one fire here I got Ivan get rid of
and we got [ __ ] I'll tell you who we
got here
Vaughn theof on fire we got Vaughn fire
that's you Nick
you're not Nick [ __ ] that people know
you people don't know who one fire is
people don't know who Ivan get rid of is
but they know who [ __ ] Vaughn fire is
this straight-up German dude
hello I am Vaughn fire would you like to
guess host on this past weekend hello my
name is Vaughn fire would you like to
guess house on this past weekend
would you like to guest host on this
past week couldn't what Wow he was a
very good man yeah we have to it must
respect for him I was watching a
speaking of like I was watching now what
he call that movie gladiator with
Russell Crowe dude how much is Russell
Crowe by the way man when I when I was a
kid I watched gladiator guess what I
thought Russell Crowe is gonna be fat
dude if you couldn't tell Russell Crowe
is gonna be a fat guy when he got 60
I'll tell you what you want you truly
you're one of the dumbest people in the
[ __ ] world that guy looks like he was
holding it in at 35 more than me eaten
that you using that [ __ ] Metamucil
that psyllium husk bro when I use that
psyllium husk I keep that [ __ ] in one
day later you let those [ __ ] Airy
farts out bro so anyway oh yeah I was
watching the gladiator that's one of
those movies by the way you watch once
it's great but that's it
Braveheart once these are the movies
once Green Mile once these are the
movies dude Forrest Gump once once these
people are so great look I did I'd have
buddy in high school or uh yeah high
school he would watch Braveheart all the
time I brought how he's like it's my
favorite movie I'm like yeah but dude
how many times you gonna watch a guy get
get his nuts cut off and scream freedom
you [ __ ] weirdo watch a comedy
ah watch swingers watch [ __ ]
dodgeball I don't give a [ __ ] watch you
know Big Daddy with Adam Sandler who
[Music]
anyway uh yeah so I saw this [ __ ] the
other day let me get into this I'm
having fun but let me get into this [ __ ]
dude I saw this these ladies talking
online um I've got to check out the one
fire text I told it to him the angelic
initiative this is crazy the angelic
dude HP keyboards are like different
they're like [ __ ] straight-up they
have dip that did you know that the
letter the letters are in different
places yep they are and you're like what
if he doesn't give a [ __ ] dude you know
who made HP computers some guys they
just some guys they will make HP
computers over here oh yeah I got keys
cool throw them on which way did they go
it don't matter put that [ __ ] on there
that's where you could put the G right
there look there's his face
look there's an R put the H and P
together because that's our company do
it so I check these these chicks online
by the way if I ever have a daughter I'm
gonna say I had a chick hey guys what
you have I had to check alright so here
we go these are the these two girls who
are a celebra they're sitting in these
white chairs and they always have their
arms up and they talk like this and
friends if you kill this recording we
have so many backup first of all girl
back up okay
you're eating the microphone recorders
going right now if you kill this
recording all this other girl says is
that is true that's true in weird ass
creepy
no never hits a note like when people
talk its melodic as death done yeah I'm
talking on this on that that's a [ __ ]
be sharp this is an a-flat that's this
that's a regular see she's like that's
true that those aren't even notes dude
this girl is a genius how she finds
music alright so there's two ladies the
microphones are taped on their [ __ ]
shirts and they're sitting in deck like
deck chairs and one girl they always
have their arms up and they're just like
reaching you can see on the video
podcast but if you're just listening to
it you won't and they just talked about
I don't know me theory I'm friends if
you kill this recording we have so many
backup recorders going right now if you
kill this recording like what is she oh
she says a couple others I mean why
would she be lying about that we have so
many backup recordings here that is true
okay hey how abou been that you think
she's lying about backup recordings do
you want to think about what it makes
you look like because you're giving us
the assignments to do this we're
channeling in this is a bounce point
always an echo point doesn't it make you
look like you don't want to follow
advice from wiser mines above you her
arms have never been below her head by
the way my friends in Planet Earth
dating it's Saturday February 16th
my friends in Planet Earth dating it's
Saturday I was it 2019 okay
in both fill in life and the Jamie body
mind the authorized Souls remain only
child bro
authorized Souls okay keep WEP
out of this girl's pantry both from the
deeper I mean dude anybody saying
authorized souls will murder you like
straight-up think about that for real
anybody using the words together
authorized Souls like this girl says for
sure she says manifesto for sure she
says you know higher being no doubt for
sure she says you know well let's just
see what she says here denser dimensions
and oh there we go dimensions other
Souls from all of the dimensions as long
as the souls are already contributing
more to completing the search for truth
assignments than they are taking or
using or borrowing and search for truth
resources since that's one of the
foundational rules of the search for
truth community not rules that by the
way the other girl right now is saying
oh if that's true bro what is this lady
talking about who's filming this dude
this is like the liberal version of
[ __ ] the thought boyfriend that's
like shooting the the girl eating
[ __ ] pizza for her Instagram these
presences have come up with but rules
that have been given to these presences
and these presences are charged with the
responsibility of enforcing what girl's
rules completing the assignments
ourselves take use or borrow is a
hallmark of the effort ask not what this
project can do for us but ask what
together we can do in all dimensions and
for all categories have sent dude I mean
oh my god imagine having dinner with
this lady you'd be like hey I'm sorry I
have to [ __ ] all over the table another
go back that's true how are we going to
clean this up when our hands have to be
up in the air that's true some guy just
comments under it that's true
I mean somebody else wrote can't get
enough of episode 651 like dude there's
there's over a thousand episodes who
gets passed are you guys looking at this
or no
you do know just dance inside of those
dimensions what I mean do - who gets
passed since that's what our soul
contracts commit us to do is that's what
our soul contracts commit us to do
who gets passed that
that's true that's true this topic of
contributing is big in the search for
truth effort right so real people we've
been attempting to being helped by the
way this video is six minutes that human
society humans have stolen the planet
that's true and therefore the solutions
have to come from the humans also
because nobody else has any resources
what's doing on the other girl who just
says that's true such a follower it's
it's a it's a humans problem that the
planet is [ __ ] up so it's the Pugh
it's the humans that are gonna have to
that's true that fix it that's true this
girl if she was like straight up if she
was straight up like kill somebody for
me she'd be like that's true [ __ ]
dude she would stab you you know what
she would do pretend she's your friend
just to if this lady said she pretend
she's your friend and then [ __ ] stab
you in the front and look at you in your
eyes and you'd be like oh and she'd
think I have to do it in the front
because it's respectful and then you'd
be like you killed me and she'd be like
that's true
throw you'd [ __ ] it [ __ ] and die how
about that
by the way I [ __ ] was listening just
to you know prep a little bit for the
podcast um this is what I heard [ __ ]
Theo say on his last podcast which is
crazy to me
I'm just gonna play a little bit of it
right here here we go
ah and dude I'd never been to a NASCAR
race
hey what dude your hair though you've
never what
hey NASCAR is the thing where everybody
from Louisiana goes and watches cars
ride around and laps for 7,000 laps
you've done that because of your face
you'd never been to a NASCAR the [ __ ]
that's like me saying I've never stepped
inside of an All Saints what about your
hair though
dude that's that when I listened to it
and it was the episode with [ __ ]
Vaughn fire and I just I was all right
you know what if he's gonna lie dude to
his own people I'm out I'm out
I stopped it and I [ __ ] pulled over
and I sat for a little bit and I just
went like this
like how your mom like if you cheat on
your girl how she looks Wow
well I hope it was fun
if that girl was next to him when Theo
said that she'd be like that's not true
well how dude
I mean never been to a NASCAR if you
were a transformer you would transform
into one of those cars and it would say
tied on the front okay
he would say Castrol GT on your ass
anyway dude I can't get enough of these
ladies the angelic Initiative the
angelic initiative every I mean
there
[Music]
every episode over there's one where
she's laying down Earth's foot dragging
feet although that's true girl is
talking to öland feet her problem feet
have this feeling of just needing to
shoosh the energy downward oh and I
wonder if we merge in better for all of
us these messages are about and we swish
all of us to our right places if I mean
they they couldn't sound more like
they're [ __ ] about to yawn the whole
time and if we're just trying to source
you once more uh anyway dude dude should
we take some of these things should we
do these things these video or these
starting up video the phone call
messages right this is an HP but I'll
figure it out this is an HP but I'll
figure out this sound bored of it all
these guys call in I guess you know if
you listen to the [ __ ] thing what is
it these are all all three of these are
all four all six of these are things
well what's the first two the first two
are different ones okay cool alright
cool and then I just comment on it yeah
what up see oh this is first of all it's
Chris Indianapolis went there did a show
thank you
I'm assuming you probably didn't come
because you're a Thiel fan maybe you're
not a crystal Lea fan but you should
have came I was just there and you
missed it and I'm sure Theo will be
there at some point but it doesn't
[ __ ] matter anyway because this is
this past weekend right now with guest
house Chris D'Elia
April falls you asked about when do I
listen to your podcast well never I
listen to it about every morning before
work but right now I'm listening to it
on my way down to Georgia about to go
meet up with my boys from Columbia
Mississippi actually I met these fools
on the hiking the Appalachian Trail all
the way from Georgia to Maine 2,200
miles on foot six and a half months
living out of my backpack listening to
your podcast makes me feel like I'm
hanging out with them because I can't
always be with them obviously I'm living
it in
they live down in Mississippi but you
just give me that same vibe that there's
southern boys do and it warns my heart
man not to get all soft on you or
anything but hey man I appreciate
everything you do and you can be
inspiration for for everything in my
life right now staying staying clean
staying you know keeping off of the dark
arts you know I'm saying but uh getting
Goering brenna only wearing his shirt
the whole time him only wearing a shirt
no pants no underwear just a shirt dude
I that that's first of all you got sweet
on me dude you got sweet on me at the
end so I couldn't [ __ ] roast you but
dude so here's the thing man you're
keeping clean and sober that's [ __ ]
legit and I appreciate all fans okay
now I'm not saying that you're my fan
maybe you are maybe listen to me maybe
you don't but you do this in a Theo so
he appreciates that I know and I do
appreciate all fans and that's awesome
and I appreciate even people who aren't
fans you're going through your own [ __ ]
and maybe you talk [ __ ] you pop off on
Twitter and I had to clap back and you
know maybe you stepped into a Denny's I
don't know but my point is with that
message actually more of my point is
Thea's asking who's listening and you
replying that message and before it got
sweet made me break the fourth wall to
nobody okay I just looked at nothing and
when ah you're cute though bro you
really are cue from indie a police
whoever the [ __ ] Indianapolis well what
was the [ __ ] thing Gronkowski said
Minnie Annapolis uh idiot hey Gronkowski
hahaha
CTE um dude Gronkowski's gonna be [ __ ]
I know he's the besa he's great but do
it when he's like 50 someone's gonna be
like you want mayonnaise on your
sandwich and he's just gonna be like 40
and just died that's how much CTE hates
gonna have shout-out to Indianapolis
Indian in Annapolis you're killing it
that's very cool keeping it keeping it
clean I keep it clean - I've never done
drugs in my life never done drink and so
we're just we're a lot alike except we
don't drive down to Georgia I don't do
that but you do that and that's
that's your life keep it together and
you're the man dude and put on some
pants cuz you absolutely left that
message is only a [ __ ] Bart Simpson
shirt on hey we asked about the [ __ ]
best worst weekend people describe why
they had the best first weekend here we
go
first of all said way too many names in
the beginning of that I would up the oh
this is your boy Nick in Bryan Texas so
many names said five words three of them
were names hey guy hey Theo what's up
its Nick I mean Bryan Texas Philip
Steven Stacy so Robert we were just
Vincent hanging and so dumb Antonio we
ate some Vincent sushi and by the way
already doubled up on names that's how
dumb I am doubled up on name said six
name said Vincent twice idiot never
submitted I just want to hear that
alright I'll be the judge of that bro
okay [ __ ] Kreskin alright David
Copperfield David Copperfield you're
Jewish did the David Copperfield thing
that [ __ ] was gangster dude let him die
you know why he got a [ __ ] he what is
he 98 no he did a lame joke and touched
my ass let him die
you know oh he's just gonna die what do
you want what do you want to snap his
neck ye dude if you're 96 you just be
like okay yeah you [ __ ] touch my eyes
you know George Bush is like all right
I'm in a wheelchair I'm dead I'm dead
tomorrow lady oq first child for a lot
of you in the eyes of a child everybody
feels like that but then so my wife's at
the 36 grueling hours and hard labor and
so finally they decided that she'd be
better off of the feedback committee
I don't think there's any shame in that
of course not
but she was so beautiful as you just
can't see was a champion for everything
and then the watcher hold my son our son
it's the most beautiful thing I've ever
seen the more in love with her than ever
Wow then anyway I want to go on too long
but yeah man have you never known how
much you can love until you've looked
into the eyes of your baby your baby
anyways god bless you deal appreciate
everything you do and if you could I
don't know I'm dropping email or thumb I
wanna send pictures into you just
because damn it I like then why all
right later I love this guy what if at
the end he went psych I don't have a kid
[ __ ] you doo doo doo poo if you'd like
to make a call please hang up and try
again
um no that's [ __ ] Swedish [ __ ] man
goddamn that's what everybody says ha
when they have a kid you don't know love
until you see your kid I want to be like
you're the dark part of me wants to be
like that so egotistical and that's so
self-centered because it's a version of
you but dude that's beautiful man that's
[ __ ] cool to hear that guys genuine
voice say that [ __ ] man Wow
I know I'm not Theo but [ __ ] that you
know what actually for this message I am
because I'm gonna pretend like that was
for me I needed to hear that bro and
even though it's a little disappointing
because it's not Theo [ __ ] he'll hear
it too because he'll listen to this but
that was that was awesome
congratulations on your first child and
that's really sweet and we hope you're a
good dad man we do and also you know
it's crazy to think about one day like
that's so something first of all you
can't go back on now you can't go back
on not having kids you can't go back on
having kids you have a kid you have kids
that's it you made a [ __ ] baby and
that [ __ ] came out of your girl's vagina
and you got to take care of that [ __ ]
and it's just crazy to think that one
day one day dude I'm listening to you
right now one day I'll have a kid and or
two or three but not more than that
because I'm not Mormon and uh
I'll have a kid and I'll think about
this message I'm all probably won think
about it while the birth is happening
because it'd be very weird but I'll
think about it later and it's just crazy
that you know Thea will never
experienced that because you have to
Louisville first of all look we get into
a loving relationship with a woman and
Theo so [ __ ] up and would never be
able to hold that down for long enough
not to mention would you know he's
actually sterile which sucks but I know
for a fact he's sterile but you have to
get a girl to fall in love with you and
how are you gonna do that because of
just the whole face thing right so and
also you're a Europe and I hate to say
this on your own pockets but you're a
goddamn liar right because of the whole
[ __ ] NASCAR thing that you tried to
we're gonna call that NASCAR gate is
what we're gonna call it because that's
a goddamn lie
right so cuz your hair so long that some
[ __ ] wives are like oh that's the
Train I want on my dress for my wedding
day when Theo goes to weddings Brides
think he's trying to upstage them that's
how long the Train on the back of his
mullet is so you if you were real Theo
you would have to [ __ ] work men just
holding the sides of your mullet like
you're a goddamn bride that if I had a
mullet bro that's what I'm gonna do I'm
gonna get a mullet for real and I'm
gonna do that I'm gonna have guards just
hold my hair when I walk to the comedy
store just hold the [ __ ] out of it even
if it's short just have them hold it who
gives a [ __ ] alright cool we got general
voice mails here poppin off right here
anyway congratulations bro on the on the
firstborn that's really great and don't
be like oh I know everybody thinks that
no man take your moment live in it
that's really good
you don't have to you don't have to feel
you know you are it is special dude
you're a special guy you had a [ __ ]
special kid now it's time to do the work
man and raise that [ __ ] great yo
what's happening man it's Ryan from
Truckee that's right there by Lake Tahoe
made up a place announces Nearpod cabin
I just wanted to say that this month I
just hit four years clean nice no uh not
that four years I would have never
thought I could have done it but anyways
I guess my question was I never thought
you could either bro but that's not
because I think negatively of you it's
just cuz I didn't know you existed until
now so the fact that you're doing it I
do believe in you and now that I know
you're a person I think you can keep
going you went four years and every
day's hard I guess you know I I don't
know but I hear this I have a lot of
friends in the program and [ __ ] like
that and they get started oh my god
super fast but the only thing is you
kind of like reminds me myself back when
I used to be going hard I mean so you
know when we hang out Dana girl that is
uh she still parties and your gear
you're clean I get what you're saying
and let's see a large white pool and do
[ __ ] like that it and that's all it's
good fun but I was just saying if you
had any experience with that like if you
just stopped going out to bars or so do
go to bars and it's just boring being
around I look drunk people or something
like that so anyways people could touch
on that really quick okay gang man have
a good day bye so I know Theo very well
and I know that he doesn't go to bars
and because I know the reason why is
because he's weird as [ __ ] dude and if
you wanna like go eat after a comedy
store after a comedy store sabe let's go
eat be a bunch of us gonna eat fun
people meet Bobby Lee whoever the [ __ ]
we're all going to eat Bryan Callen and
field will just be like oh man I gotta
[ __ ] pack some bags and you'll be
like what you're going to the airport
early tomorrow it'll be like nah and
you'll be like huh and then I'll just
leave you be what [ __ ] bags you have
to pack and I'll just be like Gang Gang
and you're like he's just a weirdest
[ __ ] one thing I know Theo won't go
somewhere if you don't want theater go
somewhere just invite him to that place
that's the thing he has to show up dude
we went to dinner recently a bunch of us
me and cheeto Santino whatever his real
name is and a bunch of other comedians
that you've never [ __ ] heard of but
are amazing I'm kidding you know you
know but uh just
and so he came and Theo came and and and
we were like Theo's not gonna show up
and he showed up and one of us said I
can't remember who it was I don't think
it was me it was like how much is gonna
show up for 25 minutes and leave and
sure enough that's what he did he showed
up
[ __ ] 35 minutes in ordered didn't
wait for the food to come and left 25
minutes later then the food got there I
ate it like a fat [ __ ] and and I was
like why do you need to leave and he was
like we forgot to do ads on our [ __ ]
podcast man gotta go back and do ads
like just do the ads when you do the
[ __ ] podcast Gang Gang come on dude
you didn't sit and eat [ __ ] we're all
bullshitting
we don't get together for dinner that
much Judi was there for 25 minutes
I gotta go drive over the west side man
do my ads for like gray block pizza or
some [ __ ] oh it's on the way to the
beach
what Beach [ __ ] how vague are your
ads gray block pizza you know we got
gray block pizza if you never had cheese
and meat on some sort of dough before if
you never had cheese and meat all
crammed together like is it some Incubus
concert
that's not feel that's not feel be like
you ever been to [ __ ] you've been an
incubus concert to see people all
crammed together that's what the the
meat and cheese are like together like
the cheese is your lady and you're the
meat and you're taking into an incubus
concert and you're just chilling on some
dough but but and they're just about to
play wish you were here and that's what
you are you never have put that in your
mouth that's an incubus concert in your
mouth if you never did that you got to
go to grey block pizza I'm not gonna
give you the address but it's near the
[ __ ] beach somewhere huh such a bad
ad such a bad ad ha that's true it's a
bad ad that's true through
I don't mean to get all disrespectful on
you but that's a bad add gray block
peach sits in a gray building somewhere
it's next to a tan [ __ ] bit
nondescript building where they sell
life insurance I think probably great
people great black Petes are like oh
this is everyone this is everyone at
grey block pizza ad agency well at that
the gray bought pizza when when they
hear a Theo's ad for grab up is a this
is it this is them this is every time
and they go like this where is he hey
why do you have this you're alone in a
room talking for an hour in ten minutes
don't have a knife behind you for [ __ ]
sake what was I saying about the [ __ ]
great black pizza yeah so anyway alright
so what else we got another one for here
we go CEO Vince from Boulder I just seen
Chris D'Elia did I am universe with you
[ __ ] dress is pretty weird I thought
you were being you know a little hard on
the guy he had a lot of that really did
he's [ __ ] weird dude
everything he wears I just he was like a
Lily's like I'm kind of like punk rocker
thing for babies yeah really you know
eighties anyway that's right it not
super impressed when you come into
Boulder man no bro let me tell you
something [ __ ] guy who goes to a
crystally a show and thinks about what
he wears and then leaves a message on a
guy's phone that he doesn't know about
it I'm not the weirdo go get yourself
you know what dude hey you know what guy
who whose money
I now have go to the beach and get some
[ __ ] gray block pizza find it find it
also oh oh dude you rat that Boulder
show oh dude you this guy's from Boulder
right for was this before oh dude oh I'm
so glad you brought this up dude you're
in Boulder dude
let me tell you something Boulder
audiences are the [ __ ] worst
you're the worst dude not in the party
way San Diego is the worst in the
[ __ ] whoo yeah Boulder get out of
your own [ __ ] ass Boulder they would
you were offended at everything this
guy's offended with me dressing like a
[ __ ] by the way look how my dress bro
black-on-black dude I'm just like Jason
Statham when he's not shooting I'm
dressed like Jason's Jason Statham in
between scenes on [ __ ] I Calvin and
Hobbes or whatever the [ __ ] movie is
[Laughter]
Hobbes and Shaw did the I'm in between
the rock days baby I'm dressed like
Statham dude dude those crowds that
Boulder were some to write about they
were [ __ ] I hated those shows dude
did to sold out did to sold out you're a
part of it
wow that's so funny you were in those
audiences those were the worst they made
them close to God that's so weird that
you're from that show and those were the
ones that I disliked maybe the most oh
wow that's hot as [ __ ]
what do you say he wasn't impressed bro
let me tell you something you were
impressed I have on [ __ ] Nike their
air span twos and their desert their
Desert Storm shoes bro what was I even
wear by the way I literally had on jeans
and a [ __ ] t-shirt you weird guy okay
so anyway shout-out to you though five
here we go hey Theo this is Blake from
Texas you know man I'm calling about a
comment you made on podcast a while ago
about how you know you'll get oh you get
a scent in your nose and it'll take you
back to a time in your life I kind of
had that on a bro that's just why was
talking about when I sat here and
[ __ ] smelled Theo how weird is that
how beautiful is that I would come full
circle you know how beautiful is that
that we come full circle a business trip
recently I'm up here and Winnipeg Canada
right now been there loved Winnipeg
Canada audiences by the way they [ __ ]
rep every time I go to Winnipeg it's
February and freezing move but you rep
when on the plane right over they set me
next to this real old Filipino lady
I'm not lying dude okay well judging by
where this come the way this message is
going and with your accent it's good end
up being racist so I sat next to who hey
who are you king of the hill so I sat
next to a Filipino lady on a plane and I
didn't really know what was happening
but I had this scent in my nose from
when I was a kid and another Filipino
lady and she smelled like that one do
they all smell the same this old lady
smelled exactly like the inside of my
mom's purse okay
racist that's that's gangster to have a
nose like that though that's like a
in an x-man that just like his power
short-circuited wasn't like I'm doing
nothing to help mankind but you smell
like the inside of my mom's purse
I know we need to catch the villains but
you smell like the inside of my mom's
purse and that does nothing for our
mission but we still need to get magneto
yes I understand but I can't get you you
you're a [ __ ] you smell like a purse
you know so it really brought me back my
mom's been dead for about 12 years and
sad and this old lady on my side
whatever was I have anything do with it
oh because this is mom's purse I'm
stepping on her she don't and creepy I'm
sniffing on this lady next to me in the
end up on the plane and even though all
the emotion she's bringing out of me Wow
you know so and maybe it made me feel
good you know and it made me think of my
mom and it made me think you well that's
real that's weird to me anything yeah I
got a question for you hard you thought
I'd call up and cool let you know man so
it's Gang Gang I have a question for you
what are you doing smelling the inside
of your mom's purse mom yeah um are you
going anywhere soon
no okay
ah smells like a Filipino lady smells
like a Filipino lady in the future in an
airplane in the future what if he just
[ __ ] straight-up turned to the
Filipino lady and said you smell like
the inside of my dad mom's purse the
lady would be like that's nice
boom can you please remove him what what
I do sir you're going to jail for
weirdness they may what are you in here
for um I told an old Filipino lady she
smelled like the inside of my dad never
mind I [ __ ] boys okay well you win no
you do turn around oh boy this feels
like the inside of my mom's purse and
then they just realized that the guy's
crazy and just can't stop talking about
the guns your dick and my eyes feels
like the inside of my mom's purse in my
eyes are you Filipino we got the wrong
guy here's another one hey what up do
that's your boy Larry from Albuquerque
New Mexico
it you know nobody's ever met anybody
what's up it's your boy didn't know you
existed one the second ago what if he
was like by the way I smelled the inside
of that lady's purse didn't smell
anything like that
I smelled that Filipino didn't anything
lacked I got dead moms inside of that
come on purse dude a [ __ ] up scent
that sends but you know I all of it and
we're a couple weeks into the new year
and I have a dilemma with my girl every
time we have sex she's always trying to
stick your tongue up in the butt crack
hey man hey what what do you mean all
waste tryna how do you constantly keep
getting almost in that position if you
don't want it hey dude if I don't like
Western bagel I don't go near Western
bagel
if [ __ ] those bagels [ __ ] those bagels
how about you stop grabbing your ankles
in bed hey buddy
stop putting your nose near your [ __ ] I
don't like it yeah hey I got some for ya
yeah you down
this guy imagine this guy just [ __ ]
sitting here just like this just like
this
hey no I can't stand no what I hate when
people eat my [ __ ] in podcast rooms
that's what I [ __ ] can't stand you
know what I mean that [ __ ] bothers me
right I can't stand when I'm in a
[ __ ] 8x4 room with with with [ __ ]
boots and belts in it and a painting of
Chris Farley and guys eat my [ __ ]
that's what I can't stand
we gotta cut that out down way bro you
like it man and that's okay I have an
idea that he probably does this Chris
bleep attorney type of uh I don't know
anything for me as far as I can do with
that oh I do I'm not appreciated man oh
I do
Oh gang gang oh I do dude go to a I've
got an idea for you go to a construction
site turn around and back up you'll get
what you want you'll get what you want
go to the closest firehouse knock on the
door turn around and when you hear a
backup
I mean man it's okay dude I don't know
how I keep getting in this position but
oh man
whatever dude I gotta go you know I
don't know what the [ __ ] is wrong with
you guys I love you
but April Fool's we're all [ __ ] aren't
we man I'm so [ __ ]
what's that oh yeah we go out with some
shine dude I'm so [ __ ] and that's okay
we're all [ __ ] together aren't we
because just remember deliver Yolo just
remember diddly wad Leo Leo leo
[Music]
I'm just sitting on your front porch
wondering how could I be so far from my
home and my mind is somewhere else but
when I found it I'll patch up where it's
been grown now I'm just floating on the
breeze and I feel up tall and like these
leaves I must be honest oh oh but when I
reach that round I'll share this peace
of mind I can feel it in my thought it's
gonna take
a little time for me to slap that pocket
break myself
[Music]